I had the pleasure of working with you
about a year ago a little over your shot
something in London together and you
were absolutely hilarious we shot a bit
where we're riding around in a car and
you were I was with you I think for
several hours and you were various the
whole time many many of us many more
than you wanted to be and and I feel I
had a broken foot if you had a broken
foot at the time you were trapped with
me yes and the car and what was amazing
is I was talking to you and you were you
were being you were so funny and the
comedy we were doing you were playing it
so well and I was telling people oh my
god Tom Cruise is he's so great when he
does a comedy and then I remembered oh
wait a minute you did it in Tropic
Thunder
look I love comma days to write sketches
when I was a little kid now we do
imitations to make my mother my sisters
laugh but les grossman is a fun
character that was a while wait I want
to take a quick while let's just go
because I remembered at the time seeing
that and and I think all of us were
completely blown away because you you
went this computer's completely
different side of you just a quick look
at les grossman listen seconds wait
[Applause]
is this true that you took did you take
things very seriously you are
perfectionist you took hip-hop classes
to prepare to be les grossman is that
right I actually I take classes all the
time to learn things or I want to prove
a skill whether it's whatever I'm you
know singing music things subject I'm
studying so I take dance classes and I
took hip-hop classes and then what I'll
find is I'll find a character to put
that with so then it's good buddy mine's
difensa teller he called me up and I
said look I'd love to play this
character but I want to have fat hands
and I'm gonna dance requests I know I
said look I just I don't know what to
say like sometimes with a character you
just get an instinct on what you want to
do and I I just know I really want bad
hands I'm going to dance and benders
like it just looks at me like you know
he's just like right out of the movies
you know where he's yeah yeah yeah that
Ben Stiller that men look we're like
okay like I don't know what is it what
what's happening here yeah yeah what's
happening so for I remember about a
couple of months he kept saying you know
maybe we don't do the makeup and maybe
just look at yourself I said no Ben I
said I really I need bad hands I'm gonna
dance and so he created the makeup and
we did the makeup test and I just
started showing him we just you know as
you're working a character you start
becoming that character you start
discovering the character and I just I
just started moving you know and there
was no music he was just looking at me
like what's happening I was doing kind
of movement then I was crushing you know
Pepsi cans and cool and then he calls me
the next day and he cut it to that piece
of music to that piece of music that you
see in the movie because I get it I get
it I get it it's larious the and if I'm
not mistaken les grossman you've all
your characters have iconic lines les
grossman had an iconic line you do you
want to you want to maybe bring that
back for us
Playa Playa Playa Playa Playa and the
other one saying yeah it's we like to
say that yes what we can cut around okay
look you can do whatever we want here
you stand back and literally your own
face
[Applause]